The File Allocation Table format was originally used in
the late 1970's on floppy disks, and became the
standard in DOS and early Windows machines. It is
still commonly used on solid state and flash memory devices
like this one. As these storage technologies have evolved,
it has gone through many iterations, but the two key
ideas have remained the same. The first is that
each filed is represented as a linked list of blocks.
Normally when we think of a link list we think of
the links as being part of the nodes in the list.
May the last part of the block would give the ID
of the next block. Here however the links in this list
are represented in the final allocation table, which is indexed by
block number. Given the starting block number of the file, I
can find the next block with a constant time access to
the file allocation table. A special value, negative one in this example,
indicates that a block is the last in the chain.
This file allocation table also contains a bit to say whether
a block is free or not. In this example, our file
starts with block two. Looking at the table, I see that
the next block is six. Looking at six in the table,
I see that the next block is three. Again going back
to the table, I see that the next block is five.
And when I look at five in the table, I see
that its next has the special value indicating that
we've reached the end of the file. It's important to
realize that the file allocation table, or FAT for short,
stores all the links for all the files. For instance,
there appears to be another file occupying block four
and only block four, since that's the end. And also
one occupying block one. So the file allocation table tells
us how to glue the blocks of a file together.
But it doesn't tell us where to start these
chains of blocks. That is the function of the directory
tables. Directories as I should say are indeed treated as
files. And they use something called a Directory Table Format.
Entries in the table all have the same width
and contain the essential information, including the file name, the
starting block, and any other metadata associated with the file,
such as permissions. The root file directory has a fixed
address on the disk. So we always know how
to get started. Let's say that I wanted the content
of a file / foo / file.txt. I would first
consult this root directory table. It would tell me that
there is indeed a directory named foo, and give me
the starting block of that file. I would then access
that file on the disc and since it's a directory,
I would look through there for the file name .txt.
And it would tell me that the starting block is two. I can then chain together
the blocks on disk as we did earlier
using the file allocation table. To summarize then, the
FAT or file allocation table serves as the
glue that chains the blocks of a file together.
The directory files capture the hierarchy and the
starting blocks for the files and all the metadata.